le temps avance et cela fait maintenant
déjà six mois que star wars 8 est sorti
nous sommes donc maintenant en attente
de star wars 9
néanmoins le film reste très secret pour
le moment et les informations sur star
wars 9 se font rares et malgré ce peu
d'informations j'aimerais qu'on essaie
de faire un petit point sur tout ce
qu'on sait à propos de ce star wars 9
alors voyons voir dans cette vidéo ce
qu'on peut en tirer
[Musique]
star wars 9 a été écrit par jj abrams le
réalisateur de star wars 7 et chris
terrio un nouveau chez lucasfilm puisque
c'est son premier film pour star wars
avec cet épisode 9
il a été l'un des reals du grand film
argo ou encore batman versus superman ou
bien justice league
il est surtout là pour épauler abrams
qui reste quand même mettre du film le
film devait être écrit à la base par
coline très vauxrot le réalisateur de
jurassic world mais malheureusement ce
dernier a préféré se retirer à cause de
quelques mésententes avec lucasfilm
personnellement je trouve ça pas plus
mal que jj abrams et repris le flambeau
de ce qu'il a instaurée car on va pas se
le cacher le changement de reals à
chaque nouveau film star wars de la
nouvelle trilogie
et franchement l'un des plus gros point
faible de la saga du coup pour moi on
peut dire ce qu'on veut mais abrams est
le plus légitime à produire cet épisode
9 et je suis content que ça soit lui qui
s'en occupe
pour continuer en ce qui concerne le
tournage on sait qu'il débutera à partir
de juillet 2018
mais bon c'est pas très important en soi
le savoir en revanche pour la date
officielle star wars 9 est prévue pour
décembre 2019 le 18 plus précisément
était à la base prévu pour mai 2019
mais bon carrie fisher est maintenant
décédé l'actrice de notre chère
princesse leia et on va pas se le cacher
sa légèrement beaucoup perturbé les
plans de disney a par rapport à ce film
car effectivement suite à la mort de
carrie fisher le scénario a donc été
totalement réécrit par jj abrams et du
coup a été retardée de sept mois enfin
chose qui est quand même très importante
a notifié et que star wars 9 clôturera
la dernière prestation de john williams
qui clôturera sa grande carrière de
compositeur
avec le neuvième opus de la saga star
wars il prendra donc sa retraite à l'âge
de 86 ans mais bref passons à la suite
[Musique]
en ce qui concerne le casting bien
évidemment nous retrouverons désirade
l'est dans le rôle de ray john boyega
dents fines adam driver dans kyle
lorraine et peau d'iron avec oscar isaac
je pense qu'il est évident d'affirmer
que l'udc soit mark hamill sera de
retour dans ce nouvel opus ayant promis
à yoda de former ray et accueille
lorraine qu'il le reverra il reviendra
très certainement en force ghost comme
obi wan le fit dans les précédents opus
néanmoins le point noir reste tout de
même leia organa car comme je
l'utilisais l'actrice est maintenant
décédé
tout ceci a grandement perturbé les
plans du film disney puisqu'elle était
censé être l'objet principal de ce film
alors je ne vous cache pas qu'on arrive
à la grosse partie de la vidéo puisque
le scénario de star wars 9 est
énormément débattue tout d'abord leia
organa est un gros point d'interrogation
pour ce film pour ceux qui ne le
sauraient pas les gars devaient être
l'élément principal du film chose
logique puisque star wars 7 mettaient
énormément en avant en solo qui termina
sur sa propre mort ainsi que star wars 8
avec luc et sa mort à la fin star wars
neufs devaient tournait alors autour
d'eux les gars est donc normalement
finir sur sa mort comme ses deux
compères du coup suite à sa mort le
scénario fut totalement réécrit et du
coup nous sommes face à deux options
premièrement étant donné que le scénario
a été totalement réécrit le film
pourrait légitimement commencer avec les
funérailles de la princesse permettant à
l'aeia de nous quitter en paix et de
réadapter le film en conséquence avec un
message dans les écriteaux du début de
film
cependant seconde option qui risque de
faire grincer des dents certains et que
l'eia soit jouée par meryl streep une
grande actrice et ami de carrie fisher
c'est une rumeur lancée par le casse une
mais disney eux-mêmes et étant donné que
le rôle de leia dans le neuvième opus
est très important il pourrait se
conclure avec la reprise du rôle par
merrill malgré la véracité de cette
rumeur le fait que le scénario était
totalement champ
j'ai suite à la mort de carrie fisher va
un petit peu à l'encontre de cette idée
que meryl streep va incarner les ja dans
star wars neuf puisque chose logique si
meryl streep doit reprendre le rôle de
l'eia il n'y a donc pas de raison de
devoir changer scénario à cause de la
mort de l'actrice mais maintenant
intéressons nous à andy serkis l'acteur
de stock car ce dernier a vraiment
beaucoup apprécié jouer son personnage
et fut très déçu de devoir le quitter
assez prématurément dans star wars 8 mai
il respecte tout de même ce café ryan
johnson est vraiment très fan de la
scène de la mort de ce noble tout de
même
cependant beaucoup de rumeurs circulent
sur un potentiel retour de snow qu étant
donné que nous ne savons pas encore tous
de l'ex suprême leader malheureusement
le personnage est bel et bien mort tout
dépendra de ce que jj abrams eux choisi
de faire mais sachez que le real de star
wars 7 avait écrit de potentiel suite
pour la nouvelle trilogie qui fut
balayée par ryan johnson qui décida de
tuer snoeck et l'udc dans le huit
tout reste donc possible techniquement
tout dépend des choix de jj abrams
d'ailleurs maintenant que calais
lorraine elle suprême leader il est sûr
à 100% que nous verrons les chevaliers
de rennes dans star wars 9 qui fut
introduit dans le 7 mai auquel on n'a
jamais eu d'infos donc ils sont obligés
de les mettre dans ce star wars 9
enfin pour finir en beauté cette vidéo
on va rentrer dans du concret vraiment
dans le vif du sujet car des fuites
circulent à propos du scénario de star
wars 9 alors chien vous dire quand même
même si ces infos ne sont pas sûres à
100% rien n'est sûr à 100% c'est quand
même des infos qui ont vraiment de très
grandes chances d'être vrai et du coup
si vous ne souhaitez pas être spoilé de
star wars 9 sur le scénario savoir 9
vous conseillerais du coup de quitter
cette vidéo est pareil si vous souhaitez
mettre à un commentaire en rapport avec
ce que je vais vous dire
n'hésitez pas à mettre la mention spoil
avant votre commentaire afin de ne pas
spoiler justement ceux qui n'aimeraient
pas être spoilé je vous laisse donc cinq
secondes pour quitter la vidéo si vous
ne souhaitez pas être spoilé
alors en gros pour vous résumer la chose
courant 2016
fust foule ce break un mec avait dévoilé
une grande partie du film de star wars 8
the last jedi sur le site de reddit
gagne évidemment tout le monde lui avait
totalement rigolé au nez en affirmant
que c'était totalement du fake ce qu'il
racontait sauf que le retournement de
situation c'est que le jour où est sorti
star wars 8 the last jedi tout ce qu'ils
avaient prédit était vrai et en fait
c'est pas parce qu'il est comme paul le
poulpe ou n'importe c'est parce qu'en
fait c'est un mec qui a eu accès aux
premiers storyboard du film star wars 8
et qui du coup a pu partager des bouts
de scénario en fait à la sur la toile et
du coup comme pour le huitième film ce
mec-là a réussi à voir les premières
storyboard de star wars 9 je vous
partager ce qu'il a affirmé alors ouvrez
bien grand vos oreilles
alors l'histoire se passera cinq ans
après star wars 8 chose que nous savions
déjà à peu près remarquent que la
résistance n'est plus hyper populaire
écailles lorraine domine la galaxie en
compagnie de ses chevaliers darren eales
et même d'ailleurs un leader plutôt
bienveillants à tel point qu énormément
de personnes de la résistance se demande
pourquoi le combattre mes rêves fine
pourrait les gars savent que quelque
chose se cache sous cette bienveillance
cette bienveillance qui a d'ailleurs été
pas mal énoncés sur pas mal de sites à
propos du scénario star wars neuf comme
quoi calais lorraine serait un leader
bienveillant donc ça rajoute encore plus
de véracité à ces propos ne voulant pas
être sous l'emprise d'un empire ils
feront tout pour découvrir les secrets
du premier ordre
c'est alors qu'une taupe du premier
ordre leur viendra en aide
cette eau permettra de découvrir une
base secrète du premier ordre qui
contient prisonniers une femme
permettant de naviguer dans des régions
inconnues qui leur dévoilera par la
suite une planète secrète rempli d'eau
ou le premier ordre fait travailler de
nombreux esclaves
ce sont eux qui produisent toutes les
richesses du premier ordre l'intriguent
de la première partie du film tournera
donc autour de la libération de ces
esclaves d'ailleurs chose qui appuient
quand même pas mal encore plus les
paroles de ce mec là c'est que nous
savons
dans cet art que dans star wars 9 un
nouveau personnage féminin apparaîtra
une femme d'une quarantaine d'années
apparemment comme mentionné sur
plusieurs sites art est apparemment
devenu une protectrice de nouveaux
utilisateurs de la force
on peut penser par exemple à thé miri
blague le petit garçon là dans star wars
8 qui fait venir le ballet via la force
du coup pour continuer la seconde partie
du film sera donc autour de la chasse de
ces utilisateurs de la force par cai
lorraine et ses chevaliers
mais contre toute attente la taupe
serait apparemment le général hogg ce
qui toujours rival à kayes lorraine
cherchera à le faire tomber
et du coup enfin là la chose incroyable
qui m'a fait totalement bondir de ma
chaise en mode
quoi qu'est ce qui se passe qui je pense
devrait faire plaisir quand même à pas
mal de personnes parce que vous êtes
beaucoup à en parler je vous le cache
pas c'est la romance entre kai lorraine
ehret qui grandit énormément dans ce
film car oui justement l'utilisateur de
reddit affirme que la relation à
distance entre ray hé ben solo est
toujours d'actualité et a même évolué
puisqu'il serait secrètement amoureux
surtout la révélation du film et que ray
serait apparemment tombée enceinte de
kayes lorraine et que l'un de ses
pédales wah ne serait son enfant puisque
nous sommes après tout en marque cinq
ans après l'opus suite qu'elle l'aurait
n'apprendrait la nouvelle et tuerait
presque ray pour ceux ci qui sera sauvé
par l'eia fin de l'histoire
alors bizarrement rien ne m'étonne dans
tout ceci puisque la nouvelle saga star
wars s'inspire énormément des anciens jj
abrams s'est d'ailleurs beaucoup mais
beaucoup inspiré du quatrième opus pour
faire star wars est justement il faut
même savoir que à la base jack ou devait
être tatouine en fait tout l'intriguent
de star wars 7
ces arrêts qui la planète d'auray
c'était radio elle vient devait être
tatouine à la base et puis ce sont dix
ça fait quand même un petit peu beaucoup
de références et d'inspiration on va
créer une autre planète et du coup c'est
devenu jack ou mais à la base advese
tatouine dans ce scénario que je vais me
présenter je trouve qu'il y a quand même
énormément de ressemblance avec star
wars iii la revanche des sith justement
anakin à une romance avec pad mais qui
tombe même enceinte de anakin et qui
justement anakin à la fin de star wars
iii tuent presque doit elle tue presque
pad mais à cause de son changement etc
afin qu'il vient de qui part du côté
obscur qu'il est dans une folie un petit
peu mais du coup l'impression que c'est
un petit peu pareil avec cai lorraine
qui tuerait presque ray qui est enceinte
de lui apparemment c'est quand même
chose assez bizarre quand même et qui
s'inspire grandement du troisième volet
je trouve je vous avoue ne pas trop
savoir quoi penser tout ça en même temps
un rien ne m'étonne trop dense que je
viens de lire et pourtant tout semble
vraiment bas vrai quoi après comme le
dit fou ce fou selon elle l'utilisateur
de rat dit
toutes ces infos sont à prendre avec des
pincettes et peuvent être totalement
fausse puisque après tout le scénario a
été écrit suite à la mort de carrie
fisher étant donné qu'il a vu
apparemment les premières story board
après c'est pas quelque chose qui semble
trop toucher carrie fisher à part le
fait qu'elle sauverait à la fin de star
wars 9 apparemment du coup ci c'est le
vrai scénario a story board n'a pas dû
réellement trop changé je pense enfin
bref je vous mets quelques liens dans la
description si vous voulez avoir plus de
données à ce sujet à vos risques et
périls bien sûr - en tout cas j'espère
que ma vidéo vous aura plu
n'hésitez pas du coup on me laissait un
petit pouce bleus c'est très important
pour moi et à vous abonner à cette
chaîne youtube ci
vous désirez suivre mon contenu
n'hésitez pas à me suivre sur twitter
c'est très important aussi
et puis que le 'lion' world soit avec
vous c'était argot rock
allez ciao swing
[Musique]